welcome back to the gadget lab I'm
Michael colori and I am at the Baldwin
nice are coming up later if we're going
to have some drama from the Apple App
Store to tell you about and also we're
going to have a smartphone with a crazy
high resolution camera in it but first
robbie brought robot it's a room i'm
just keeping the arms going so this is a
brand new roomba it's it's actually
pretty cool it's basically the same room
it's it's always the same it they don't
really change too much this one I took
it home it was able to go over the link
lines for my for my carpets we have a
lot of rugs in my house you also have a
lot of cats we also have a lot of cats
which is why we gave you the fancy
robotic exactly and we vacuumed two or
three times a week at least and we added
this to help get rid of cat hair and
it's it every time I wake up you can
schedule it and I was scheduled like wow
I'm not home I come home it's full of
cat hair so it's doing its job and it
comes with these little it's a it's a
lighthouse and it'll keep it out of a
room so you can switch it from
lighthouse to or a wall if you put a
lighthouse it'll stay in a particular
room so you fare in particular when it
gets kind of dirty you want to make sure
a room but cleans that room turn that
puppy on if you want to stay have
another room just switch like a switch
and it'll stay out of the bathroom or
the bedroom or wherever you all your
expensive bases so you've you've had a
few of these before you've had one of
these before and how does this one rate
against the the older group of drugs I
think it it it cleans better and so you
know if vacuum cleaner that's that's
what a back extension was supposed to
suck all the dirt off so it actually
sucks up more dirt than our previous
versions that we had and it seems to be
able to climb up like steeper little
incline that inclines what steps it's
very cool and if you lift up this little
piece here there's a serial port in
there yeah so once you have a Roomba and
you get sick of it or it's not working
anymore there's a little serial port you
can mod them there's a whole community
online you can bother make battle bots
or whatever and it's good to go and look
and just like so what's the model number
on this is the 790 it's pricey
but it's price because it comes with
three of these it has a remote that you
can schedule you can actually run it
with this remote you can running around
the house chase your pets and it comes
with a bunch of different brushes and
everything I'm dying with suspense
what's pricey seven hundred dollars 700
hours for robot to do all of your house
work for you well at least one of them
so it's it's really really pricey it's
it's probably a out of my price range
well you can read Robbie's full review
on wire coms product reviews section
sometime within the next coming weeks
whenever Robbie gets around to filing
thanks thanks for coming on the show
thanks
Christine is here tell us what's going
on in the app store there's all sorts of
drama this week in the app store first
up a whole bunch of apps that released
updates earlier this week starting about
late Tuesday evening if you download the
update the app would just immediately
crash so all of these people are
downloading apps like angry birds space
instance to paper good reader and it
just crashes as soon as you try to open
it over and over again even if you
delete it turns out it was a it's like
it related to a drm issue with the app
store it's because it's mostly just
affecting apps that are downloaded from
like the App Store like on the iPad or
on the iPhone not so much from iTunes I
see so this is it's an apples fault yes
had they said any bad code they are
working on the fix they haven't
officially fixed it yet but it seems to
be less of a problem than it was earlier
this week it's affecting over a hundred
apps oh well he widespread so this is
basically anybody who released a new
version of their app earlier this week
in her iOS disaffected them yeah and so
Marco Arment the developer for
Instapaper he's been really vocal about
this problem and his urging developers
not to push any updates until this issue
is fixed he was screwed he is sort of
like an iOS developer community leader
at this point isn't everybody always
looks at him too yeah and there was
something else on Thursday right yes and
on Thursday we saw our first malware app
in the iOS App Store it's called like
finding call colon find I can't remember
Oh what it's supposed to do though is
it's supposed to kind of aggregate your
contacts and kind of simplify all that
mess but what it really did was secretly
upload all your address book information
to remote server
and spam all your contacts with emails
and SMS text that to download this app
that's helpful yeah yeah I'm gonna go
download it right now yeah luckily it's
not in either the iOS App Store or
Google Play so about a long scream your
friends so the malware she's been
resolved but the iOS kashyap's issue
that's an ongoing thing so maybe I'll
have an update for us next week yes
hopefully so okay we look forward to
that
alright Alexander's here hello what do
you have there i have a nokia 808
PureView smartphone so what is that big
protrusion on the back it looks like
camera yes it is a camera it's a 41
megapixel camera now that is
extraordinarily high resolution yeah
it's very very high resolution but it
uses this thing called peer review
technology so it's not really about the
megapixels it's about crunching like
seven megapixels into a 1 megapixel area
so you can't actually take like your
photo you take does not have 41 yeah a
photo you take can have anywhere between
2-230 8 megapixels but usually the sweet
spot is 8 megapixels photos look really
nice they don't have much noise and
they're really clear and it's pretty
much the best camera phone currently
available but as a phone it sucks real
it's really bad what operating system
does it run symbian oh dang operating so
inward what is your what is your
experience with symbian light been on
this phone extremely frustrating okay
that's two words but I think we get it
um so you know using it as a camera it's
pretty awesome but what about like you
know checking our email or so no yeah I
can't I couldn't even get my email setup
on this it was having problems
connecting with gmail and surfing the
web it's it's okay it's okay it's very
outdated though like if this camera was
on a phone with Windows Phone then it
would be a good smartphone okay with a
great camera but it's solid by the
software right and you can only get it
for 699 in the United States it's going
to start shipping on july 9th on amazon
but unlocked it's unlocked for AT&T and
t-mobile but it's just really expensive
so me as well to spend that money on a
camera yeah well you could read
Alexander's full review of the 808
PureView from Nokia on now boy calm yes
coming up shortly within the next week
or so and speaking of next week we'll be
back next week with more awesome stuff
from the gas
bye-bye thank you